a deadly cold snap is gripping more than
half the country this morning in western
New York the waterfront along Lake Erie
is crusted with wind-driven ice and snow
parts of the Northeast are expected to
feel wind chills of 20 to 40 degrees
below zero Maine's Rockport Harbor is
freezing over for the first time in
years Dean Reynolds is in Chicago where
at least two people died from the
freezing weather dean good morning good
morning well you can see behind me Lake
Michigan is just beginning to ice up and
Chicago officials are urging people to
stay inside and if possible off the
roads especially tonight when it's
expected to be snowing I hate it hey
then you can see your breath in the car
it's just it's crazy across the Midwest
and Northeast millions are shivering
it's very cold out I don't like the cold
weather and doing what they can to fight
the deep freeze top warn thermo two
sweaters water fountains in Philadelphia
and New York City are now mountains of
ice in New Hampshire boiling water
instantly froze due to a record
temperature of negative 34 degrees at
Chicago's Midway Airport it was too cold
to fly more than 80 flights were
canceled and nearly 250 were delayed it
was like really hectic and a whole lot
of people here Chicago emergency
officials say the temperatures can be
deadly extreme weather is more than an
inconvenience it remains a serious and
potentially life-threatening event
shelters are overflowing with people
trying to escape the brutal cold you had
pretty much down the street you freeze
to death at Jacobs is executive director
of the Franciscan outreach shelter he
says they're not turning anyone away
this bitter cold weather is extremely
dangerous a lot of our guests have
health issues already we want to make
sure they are inside where it's safe and
warm now the deep freeze is expected to
last well into next week but a it's only
a hundred and seventy four days until
summer starts we like the optin
Dean for all of us in studio thanks for
braving the cold and please get a hat we
want you to wear a hat not just the
earmuffs Dean Reynolds thank you